hundreds of thousands of people have
been displaced in recent months as the
M23 armed group Advanced towards the
city of Goma in Democratic Republic of
Congo
to the north Ugandan soldiers arrived
just over a year ago under an agreement
with Congo's government
uganda's Army says it's pursuing a
Ugandan armed group called The ADF
that's responsible for massacring
thousands of civilians rights groups say
the violence has increased since the
Ugandan troops arrived both Uganda and
Rwanda have been accused of meddling and
looting minerals ever since they first
invaded Congo in the 1990s it's not
everyone who has interest in uh in a
more stable DRC there is um
some non-states actors and perhaps even
some states actors who
need this to uh to to be going on so
that they may continue with their
traffics six months ago East African
leaders agreed to send a regional
stabilization Force Kenyan soldiers are
the latest to arrive under that Banner
Uganda Burundi and South Sudan have said
they'll also contribute troops the risk
is there that the different countries
that are intervening will you their own
narrow interests and many of these
countries have in the past particularly
the neighboring countries of Burundi
Rwanda and Uganda have supported proxy
armed groups against each other but also
against the Congolese state
more than 20 years after their mission
began the popularity of U.N peacekeepers
is at an all-time low
many Congolese blame them for failing to
protect civilians
demonstrators have burned some un
convoys and camps in recent months many
people say they're tired of foreign
forces this is the beginning that the
solution for DRC is to have a state
which is responsible a state that can
defend its territory and a state which
can also defend and protect uh human
rights of their own citizens so
militarization and uh it's not the
solution for the last uh 20 or 30 years
in DRC we have these foreign
intervention intervention and they they
didn't give the the solution and we
can't say that this Regional initiative
which is a military
initiative will have will uh Bear Foods
the M23 armed groups widely understood
to be backed by neighboring Rwanda its
Fighters have been photographed
alongside Rwandan soldiers U.N
peacekeepers have filmed hundreds of
Fighters crossing the border Rwanda
denies backing the group almost nobody
in Congo believes it in cities across
Congo people have protested against
Rwanda and Uganda who they blame for
decades of military aggression they've
called for Western powers to cut off
military aid to Rwanda the US and more
recently France and Germany have
criticized Rwanda for its support but
none of rwanda's backers have applied
sanctions
last week voter registration began for
elections that are due to be held a year
from now
leaked documents showed the last
election four years ago was rigged
president Felix chiseketti was announced
the winner he wants to run again many
people are wondering if next year's
election will be free and fair or if it
will even happen on time when you look
at the documents of the national
electoral commission it's already in
there as a factor that might delay
elections themselves so they were
they're preparing that argument
um of course no credible election can
take place if there's so much violence
that
um voting can't can't take place the
violence shows no sign of stopping n23
said it pulled out of the town of
kibumba last week following
international calls for its fighters to
withdraw and disarm it has since
continued fighting on another front
pushing towards coltan mines that it
controlled in the past more than half a
million people remain displaced from
their homes mostly because of armed
conflict
recent peace talks in Nairobi have
failed to bring any change on the ground
for now people must wait to see if the
arrival of more foreign forces in the
months ahead and the upcoming election
will make things better or worse
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera